today we're answering one of cartoons
longest-standing questions just how much
money does cruge McDuck have and his
money bin but first there's something
I've wanted to do since I was like age 7
taking a page out of your book buddy
let's do this charts and meme childhood
dreams
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to you get if I
now and man if you were a child of the
90s hearing that theme song gives you
the nostalgia tingles ducktales was then
and still is great I mean it created the
childhood fantasy of swimming through a
literal pool of gold coins which now
that I've done it it's still awesome but
is it a workout old fat pad here didn't
know what hit him
now for those of you who aren't familiar
with the show ducktales stars Donald
Duck's uncle scrooge mcduck the point
zero zero zero one percent of one
percenters with a skyscraper literally
filled with gold that overlooks his city
of duck bird you know you're rich when a
tax for the wealthy is named after you
that's right the Dutch word of the year
in 2014 was Dagobert duck tax actual
legislation named after Dagobert duck
the Dutch name for Scrooge McDuck but it
wasn't always that way Scrooge is a
testament to the value of hard work
starting as a poor shoeshine who got
sick of being taken advantage of by
heartless customers insisting that the
only valid way to acquire wealth is to
earn it Square and a vows that scrooge
mcduck swerd is as good as gold and that
grit and determination paid off making
him officially one of if not the richest
cartoon character ever created according
to countless online lists including
Forbes the business magazine he started
from the bottom and now is here so he is
quite literally Drake or more accurately
a Drake since Drake as the name for a
male duck all right but let's get real
although everyone knows Scrooge is
enormously wealthy the actual sum of
money he has is really unclear according
to the 1956 comic the second richest
duck Scrooge is worth one multiply G
lien 9 of squat to metallian 620 $3.62 a
number that gets updated in the 12 comic
series the life and times of Scrooge
McDuck 2 5 multiplied jillion 9
impossible iliyan 7 fantastic a trillion
dollars and 16 cents then if those
numbers weren't ridiculous enough for
you in season 2 episode 6 of the
original ducktales TV series the episode
liquid assets vending crack shells
Scrooge's accountant says that the
McDuck money bin contains
fifty-five oops
thirty-six uh excuse me Fenton I just
said he had five multiplied jillion are
you telling me that he lost three
hundred and twenty three fen Tilian
dollars overnight come on I think
someone here forgot to carry a one but
all joking aside obviously none of these
are actually answering our question how
fat are Scrooge's stacks in real terms
multiple outlets have tried to calculate
his worth they just don't do that good
of a job with it for instance forbes
magazine and that richest fictional
character list estimated Scrooge's
earnings in 2007 to be twenty eight
point eight billion dollars then bumped
it up to forty four point 1 billion
dollars in 2011 due to the rise in gold
prices but they never actually say where
they got those sorts of numbers and the
website the billfold uses cool equations
but misses out on just how deep
Scrooge's money bin is so with a reboot
of the series coming to Disney XD on
August 12 one that all Disney XD
sponsorship of this episode aside
legitimately looks great seems to stay
true to the spirit of the original
series and has a very cool comic
aesthetic so as someone who grew up on
these cartoons I hope it does really
well check it out if you're interested
and the question still at large after
all of these years it is time to put my
theorist hat into the ring and answer
the age-old question just how much money
does scrooge mcduck have in that famous
money bin of his now obviously with the
Disney XD series coming out I wanted to
start there
unfortunately because it's not out yet
footage right now is limited to the
trailer the opening theme song and a
couple of spare teasers so I'm not
really able to get a good sense of the
dimensions inside the bin but that
doesn't mean we're out of luck not only
do we get a good general sense of the
size and shape of the bin from the
outside looking very similar to the
design from the original TV series the
trailer gives us our first major clue
and I do mean major multitrillion-dollar
finish this is according to my research
the first time the series has put a
real-world number to Scrooge as well
putting it in the trillions but when it
comes to money that's a huge number over
20 times the highest estimates Forbes
gave him so today we
won't just be testing out how much money
he has but also how well this new reboot
knows dear old Scrooge II usually when
I'm writing these theories I need to
scrape around for whatever information I
can find this theory actually has the
opposite problem for the first time the
history of these shows there's too much
information the statistics you see about
the money men are constantly changing in
both the comics and the original series
for instance in the very first panel of
the comic only a poor man we see a depth
gauge in the money bin that reads the
building is 79 feet deep with coins and
Bill's not a shabby place to start in
another comic the pixelated parrot we
get a ton of information or more
accurately 90 tons of it since that's
supposedly how much cash ola Scrooge is
keeping in the band and earlier in that
same comic we see him counting his money
again confirming he has 9 billion
trillion into $1,000 bills stored in his
vault we even get in yet another comic
that he has three cubic acres of money
obviously a joke since an acre is a
measure of area and not volume if you
did indeed have a cubic acre you would
have created a four dimensional space he
three-dimensional space existing in a
specific time frame at that point screw
how much money as the size of his wealth
would seriously be ripping through the
laws of the universe there are even
blueprints of the money bin in the 2001
comic the Beagle boys versus the money
band we learned that the vault is
actually a 13th story building that's
127 feet tall with a large central
chamber reserved for the coins now would
be great information but the cube design
is completely different from what I'm
most interested in the TV shows been
both in the original series as well as
the reboot which we can see is taller
and more narrow so it's so much
conflicting information what do we do
well the way I see it we go to the most
reliable source on the matter episode 15
of season one of the original ducktales
TV show the money vanishes in it we see
the criminal family the Beagle boys
trick Scrooge into dousing his money
with a teleportation spray it's a plan
that's so successful they're able to
clear the vault of all its money leaving
Scrooge penniless at the bottom 20
minutes and 40 seconds into that episode
we get the
shot of the complete volume of the money
vault that we ever get across the
entirety of the series and even better
Scrooge's in it so if we're able to
identify his cannon heights we'll be
able to get a sense of scale to this
entire scene no weird exterior shots no
guessing about the accuracy of offhanded
remarks just one scene that shows us the
complete inside of the vault and gives
us the means to measure it a theorist
dream so question one how tall is
Scrooge thankfully this has an official
answer but you got a dig deep rent in
the 1963 comic for old times sake we see
villainous magic of de-spell put Scrooge
to sleep and then measure him so she can
assume his identity and sneak into the
vaults according to that panel he's just
about three feet tall or 0.91 meters now
to translate that information to the
money babe we seen the blueprints for
the money bin that the ladder that leads
to the bottom is officially canon so if
we know the height of the ladder we can
get an accurate read of the entire
building and that scene from the money
vanishes between counting the rungs you
can see and estimating the ones that are
either just slightly off screen or
aren't clearly defined near the top of
the animation you get about 30 rungs
total on the ladder but how far apart
are those rungs to figure that out we
have to go back to the very first
episode in that episode we see Scrooge
using the ladder to pull himself out of
the bend with each rung gap about a
third of his height with Scrooge being
three feet tall that means each rung is
about one foot apart and the ladder as a
whole being just about 30 feet tall that
seems low to me so let's double check
using some of that other information we
have in the very opening seconds of the
very first episode of ducktales we see
the actual depth gauge to the bolt and
it shows 70 deep seeing this I was
heartbroken but then I realized 71 70
feets it can't be because we see Scrooge
in the background if we were to measure
his size relative to that depth gauge
he'd be 20 feet tall
what is he Wario and remember that's
with scrooge further back in the shot so
perspective wise he's even smaller
relative to the depth gauge than he
normally
B and if three-foot-tall Scrooge is 20
markings on the depth gauge that means
70 markings is only about 10 feet deep
of gold even less than before so it
would appear consistent scaling in this
world is gonna have more issues than
Teen Vogue that's a magazine with a lot
of issues just so you know it was meant
to be funny but no the cringy puns are
just too real you guys so we have a
little bit of a dilemma here we have a
lot of conflicting information and I
want to go big for today's theory
I mean Disney XD pay me to do this
episode and as you all have heard on the
show time and time again they never
invite me to cool premieres or anything
so this is my chance to really impress
some love me Disney XD love it's gonna
be super thorough and earn Disney's
undying all at the lengths that we go to
on this show I'm gonna power through
every conceivable calculation I can to
see the range of money that scrooge
mcduck might be hiding in this thing
cue the clock method number one depth
gauge using the depth gauge ruler we can
Photoshop that guy out of its pile scale
it appropriately than use a few
different angles to figure out the rest
of the dimensions of the babe knowing
that 20 marks on the gauge equals about
three real feet we get a money pile
that's ten feet deep 20 feet wide and 21
feet long
that's 4,200 cubic feet of coinage
method number two the ladder method
knowing Scrooge is three feet tall we
can calculate the entry to the vault as
a circle with a diameter of about eight
feet that allows us to measure out the
walls which become 20 and 32 feet
respectively couple those numbers with
the pile that's 30 feet of gold and we
get a stack of cash that's 19200 cubic
feet method number three blueprints
since Scrooge is always diving into his
money we know the actual depth of the
coin stack is about nine floors in a
basement level with the whole building
being 12 floors above ground and 127
feet tall from ground level each floor
is gonna be about ten feet ten feet
times 10 levels equals about a hundred
foot tall mound of money looking deeper
at the blueprints we can see the width
of the bin is just under 120 feet and
the lengths that have been is 120 feet
minus 30 feet for the office rooms
making at 90 feet wide discounting two
feet on each side for the thickness of
the walls you get dimensions of 86 by
116 by 100 or 997 thousand 600 cubic
feet Smith's at number four three cubic
acres even though it's a completely
made-up number we can try to extrapolate
meaning out of Scrooge saying that he
has three cubic acres of money and acres
43,560 square feet meaning that if we
assume each side of this cube of money
is one acre in area the side length is
going to be about two hundred and eight
point seven feet cubed and you get a
volume of nine million nine thousand
nine hundred seventy-two cubic feet so
at three cubic acres Scrooge's money bin
would have contained 27 million two
hundred seventy two thousand nine
hundred sixty cubic feet in size this
number will be really fun when we do the
final totals shiver my shekels that is a
ton of gold do you love me at Disney
well don't answer just yet because this
gamer truly does have a guide to
everything that's another show on Disney
XD by the way and true to that title
we're going even deeper down this rabbit
hole because what we've just calculated
is the volume of space in the vault
across all the different scales we have
but that would imply a solid block of
money down there and that's not precise
enough this is a bunch of coins randomly
stacked coins and as my self witnessed
when hopping into the ducktales vault
for myself there's a lot of air between
those coins so in my attempt to really
impress you Disney I went and read a
bunch of papers with really boring
sounding names until I found the one
from Princeton a paper with I gotta
admit my favorite title of all time some
observations on the random packing of
hard ellipsoids watch out George RR this
is some page turn and stuff in this
paper we learn or more accurately I
learn and tell you to spare you the pain
of having to read this thing that the
packing efficiency of coins in a random
pile is about 57% meaning that almost
half that giant money pile is gonna be
nothing but air that leaves our gold
volume totals at just flash it up on
screen no one needs to hear me list off
all this stuff until we get to the final
numbers but you know what we are still
not done this is the volume of the pile
calculated in cubic feet to find the
value of this pile of gold we need to
know the weight of all of it since gold
prices are usually listed per unit of
weight so gold is really dense thereby
making it really heavy at 1206 pounds
for a cubic foot so I went ahead and
calculated out the weights and pounds
for all four of our methods which you
see listed out on screen right now
and at this point we should totally be
done right multiplied by the price of
gold wrap this episode up earn Disney's
love and respect for my super nerd dump
forever booyah I'm walking the red
carpet at the next Marvel movie premiere
because Disney XD is so grateful and how
I was able to solve their scrooge mcduck
problem except here's the catch these
are of war dupois pounds the very long
and very French name Americans use every
day when we talk about how heavy
something is there the pile of that play
gold fat pad every time he steps on a
scale it's the system where 16 ounces
equals a pound but silver gold platinum
and other precious metals that have lent
their names to pokemon installments are
valued based on the troy weight system
it's completely different when comparing
the two systems a troy ounce is heavier
than enough water ponds about 10% more
but here's for all these science and
mathematicians who created these systems
go overboard da well a troy ounce is
heavier than an award upon one troy
pound weighs less than one of water qua
pound because one troy pound is defined
as having 12 ounces not the usual 16 in
the other system I'm just just done here
that sound it is me repeatedly banging
my head against the desk so to put all
of this insanity to bed I converted all
four of our numbers to affordable houses
then to troy ounces it's worth noting
that according to method three and if
the vaults blueprints are to be believed
Scrooge's vault would contain twice the
amount of gold that exists in the entire
world and that cubic acre number yeah
that's fifty five thousand times the
amount of gold on planet Earth no wonder
Scrooge has to go to the moon in the
video games and in the opening credits
sequence of the original series and
lastly with the price of gold currently
at 1200
$43.30 per troy ounce I was finally
finally able to calculate how much gold
and Scrooge cue the drumroll we went
with method 1 the most conservative
route where he only has 10 feet of gold
per our depth gauge calculations the
money men would be filled with fifty two
billion three hundred forty eight
million four hundred ninety three
thousand seven hundred sixty seven
dollars and fifty cents that is the
lowest possible estimate of Scrooge's
wealth and would still put him as the
fifth richest person on planet earth
just behind the creator of Facebook Mark
Zuckerberg method to the ladder method
where we saw Scrooge's wealth teleported
away well that was good payday for the
Beagle boys as they would have wound up
with the greatest heist in history
walking away with over two hundred and
thirty nine billion dollars allowing
Scrooge McDuck to surge past the richest
person in the world Bill Gates and his
measly 86 billion but from here on out
the numbers get crazy method three based
on the dimensions of the comics
blueprints of the bin Scrooge would no
longer be a billionaire he'd be in the
trillions at twelve trillion four
hundred thirty four billion thirteen
million five hundred fifty two thousand
four hundred ninety dollars and ten
cents if you include his number one dime
that puts him not only past the richest
people in the world but also the richest
companies in the world don't get jelly
Disney you created him and lastly method
number four if he truly had three cubic
acres of gold a preposterous statement
it yields the equally preposterous grand
total of three hundred thirty three
trillion nine hundred twenty seven
billion six hundred thirty three million
eight hundred sixty three thousand five
hundred twenty seven dollars and ten
cents get this that's more money than
there is in the entire world
if you've added together all the
banknotes coins and money deposited and
savings are checking accounts across the
planet Earth the total is around eighty
point nine trillion dollars
rouge has four times that amount and
remember this is all just his gold coins
that's not including any jewels gems
paper money and real estate he owns
outside of that bend and here's the
craziest thing the new reboots nailed it
I was a bit skeptical when the trailer
said I excitement a monkey
trillion-dollar fish dish but there you
go they were right on the whole time so
there you have it once and for all the
final answer Scrooge McDuck trillionaire
the hands-down richest fictional
character ever not bad for a duck who
started as a shoeshine and with this
reboot coming to Disney XD starting with
a big launch event Saturday August 12
you can and should watch along with me
as Scrooge's wealth only continues to
get bigger but hey that's just a theory
ah film theory
[Music]
and cut
you